If I do my job in the next few minutes
I'm going to give you the secret to happiness
so that when you go home tonight you can
start living a happier life
and you can start sharing with more
people so that they can have
a happier life too. So let's start with
what we know about happiness.
There have been hundreds, literally hundreds, of
studies
by economists and social scientists and
psychologists about happiness,
hundreds over the past thirty and forty
years. And basically they all start by
asking the question: who's happy?
In the United States we know that all
the way back to the 1970s a
very stable proportion of the population is
very happy.
About a third of Americans say
anonymously
and in accurate tests an accurate surveys
that they're very happy people.
Okay, we have no reason to doubt that this
is true. A little over fifty percent say
they're somewhat happy,
about 10 to 15 percent of the population
is chronically depressed and say they're
not very happy.
Okay now, that's actually not the most
interesting question. The most
interesting question is what brings
happiness.
And we know the answer to that too. It's
three things,
three things bring happiness: genetics,
big life events, and choices.
And I'm going to tell you about all three,
starting with genetics.
Now, a few years ago social scientists at
the University of Minnesota
constructed a wonderful database that
included seventy five pairs of identical
twins born between the mid-1930s and the mid 1950s.
Now they were separated at birth and
adopted by separate families.
It's like a social scientist's dream
it's almost as if the government had done this.
And at age 40 they were reunited and
they were given a personality test, so
they were asked about the things that were
going on their lives and the way that they
viewed their lives.
This is really interesting because
you've got DNA carbon copies
of each other and they have different
upbringings so you can net out the parts
that are nature and the parts that are
nurture, statistically, and what did they find?
They found that 48 percent of their happiness is
genetic. As a matter of fact they found that more
of their personality was genetic than they
ever understood before. Forty percent of
how you vote is genetic
forty percent of how you worship is
genetic, so
this explains some things. Do you have
someone in your life who is
chronically happy? Do you have a coworker who's
happy all the time?
It's very irritating, by the way, and so it
sometimes you wonder, that person is
just happy all the time.
What are they doing right? What's their
secret? Their secret is
their DNA. Are you a grumpy person are you
dark and brooding. It's your DNA it's not
your fault, you have lousy parents
is basically what it comes down to. So if
that's the case
does it really matter what we do? The answer is
yeah because if half of it is taken away
from you you better get the other half right.
Now forty-percent is genetic but there are
other innate qualities, other innate
characteristics that are really
important,
the most interesting of which is gender.
Who's happier, men or women? The answer is
women.
Most studies, the overwhelming majority
of studies, find that women are happier
than men and always have been.
Okay I mean it's too bad guys but I
studied this myself and I find the same
thing. I've looked at the
happiness of men and women by marital status.
K and what do we find? Married women are happier
than married men,
single women are happier than single men,
widowed women are way happier than widowed men.
What's so funny about that?
I told that one to my wife
and she says, "Oh, no kidding."
In general women are happier than men.
Here's another interesting mystery:
what's the average
unhappiest age in a man's life? I'd heard
about this phenomenon forever, so have you,
this is the male mid-life crisis, right?
When do you think it is?
70, 17
That doesn't count, only grown ups. 45
45 it's 45 that is exactly right. 45 is the
average unhappiest age in a man's life.
And it goes something like this:
the trajectory of life for men is
interesting and
sometimes a little sad. See, when you're
in your twenties
and thirties the life recipe is
actually kind of simple.
Life is like a super highway when
you're in your twenties and thirties
if you want to get ahead and you want to have a
better life and you want to be happier and more successful
just hit the gas. Just look for more
money
and look for a better career and look
for more promotions and it's simple.
The problem is on the superhighway guys
get to age 45
and a bunch of them stop and they say
"I think I'm on the road. I don't want to be on
the superhighway, but
I can't stop because I've got the house
payment and I've got all this stuff.
It's hard, I'll get hit or get in an
accident if I stop, it'll be bad
if I stop, a whole lot of guys find.
Now, ok, next question: what do they want?
Staying on the same metaphor, what they
want is to be on another road
that they picked themselves they want to
be on a little dirt road
with a motorcycle on it where the
driver is not wearing a helmet.
That's what they want so who's the guy
on the motorcycle because the secret to happiness
is being the guy on a motorcycle without
the helmet. So I want to know who he is.
Tell me about it. I know who he is. He is me.
And I'll tell you how it works. When I
was 19,
I dropped out of college. Dropped out, kicked
out,
splitting hairs.
I ran off to play music for a living.
I was a French horn player, that was all I wanted
to do. I wound up in the Barcelona symphony
by my my late twenties. It was great, I
love the music, I still love the music,
it's the best music ever written. Seems like
a dream, right?
But I got a glimpse of my forty five
year old self.
I got to look in the crystal ball, it was
all the guys working with me,
who were usually 20-30 years older than me,
who around 45 had
kind of lost their happiness and now they
were drinking a little too much and their
marriages weren't so good and they didn't like the
music so much.
And I said I don't want to be those guys, so I got
lucky.
Because I saw it and I hatched a plan, I hatched a
plan to
to escape and I decided to go back to college.
And I called my dad and I said, "Dad I got big news!
I'm going to quit music.
I'm going to go back to college. I'm going to study, I
don't know, literature, physics,
poetry, or economics or something. It's going to
be great.
I'm going to use my brain. My dad said
"What are you talking about? You
started a family,
you're doing fine, it's very
irresponsible to just
quit when you're in your late twenties, why?"
I said, "Dad, because I'm not happy.
And I don't think I'm going to be happy.
And there's a long pause and he says
"So what makes you so special?"
Today I'm doing what I love. Today I'm
doing what I feel like I'm called to do.
Today my job is to talk to you about how
to have a happier life.
What a miracle. Now it's not good enough
for people to accidentally find the way
we need to find it on purpose. Okay so innate
differences:
genetics, forty-eight percent. The next
big one
is big life events. This is what you
think really drives your happiness.
You want to be happy? Go for your goals. You
got these big goals in life and avoid
the bad stuff, right?
You think about it all the time. If only I
can graduate from college with a good
enough GPA to get a good job, then I'll be
happy,
right? If only I get into law school then I'll
be happy if only that girl will marry me
then I'll be happy, and if I don't get sick
I won't be unhappy,
right? If I don't have an accident I won't
be unhappy. We think
in this way we are very goal-oriented
creatures.
Now how much of our life happiness at any
particular point
comes from the big things good and bad?
Answer is
forty-percent. That's a lot. It seems like you're
absolutely right to be chasing the big
thing in any particular moment, trying to
avoid the big bad thing
at any particular moment but that's
wrong. It's forty percent
but I'm going to tell you why not to chase it.
Two reasons: number one is we're very bad
at getting the things that we're seeking,
the big goals that we're seeking,
but more importantly the big things
never last.
How long will your mood be improved if you get
that dream house?
Six months. If I double your pay, how
long
will it improve your mood? Up to six
months, no more.
No matter what you do it's going to wear off,
the big stuff wears off.
But the costs of doing these big things
last forever.
Don't chase the big thing. There's
one study that really points this out.
The most interesting study I've ever seen.
From 1978 actually it's an old study, but it's
still classic.
And it compares two groups of people:
quadriplegics,
and people who win the lottery. What do
these people have in common?
A huge punctuation to the equilibrium
BOM
bad or good right? Now quadriplegics
six months after their accidents, on
average, their happiness has returned
almost to its level prior to their
accident.
That's what the study shows. Now not all the way but
almost all the way.
See how durable we are? Six months later they
would they still say I would do almost anything
to get to be able to control my arms and
legs to not be confined to a wheelchair,
but their happiness is something that is
innate,
and has to do with other forces. Okay,
that's fine study number one,
number two is lottery winners. This one's
actually even a little bit more interesting.
Six months after you hit the lottery the
average lottery winner
has permanent baseline happiness levels
that are slightly
below where they were the day before
they bought the ticket.
Literally the best thing that can happen
to you when you buy a lottery ticket
is that you don't win. Why? We know this
too.
It's because they've blown their circuits.
The little things in life
don't make them happy. Think about what is
going to make you happy this weekend.
Hanging out with loved ones, it's doing
the things that
give you a little bit of gratification
with the people who make you happy.
You're going to watch some sports,
you probably go out to dinner, you're
going to be around people who you're
comfortable with and you're going to joke
around, have a great time.
Turns out people who win the lottery don't
get that anymore. All of their hobbies
are dross their friendships are all
different they don't enjoy the little
things they used to enjoy anymore.
So they go in search for more flavor. The
truth is
if you want to be happy, don't spend your time
obsessing about the great big splash.
What you need are habits that will give you
the highest likelihood of getting that
forty percent
that will drive these events most likely
into your life
and drive the bad things out of your life
in a regular
framework as a regular type of discipline.
So what are these lifestyle elements?
And this brings us to the last 12
percent remember forty-eight is genetics,
40 percent is events, you got 12 percent
left, that 12 percent you have left
are under your control.
And if you do the things you need to do to
get the maximum from the 12 percent
you're also going to raise the likelihood
of getting the forty percent because this
gives you the best lifestyle to give
you the best luck.
So what we need to know now are the
things and there are four of them,
that will give you the 12 percent. And
this is where the knowledge is power.
This is where you get to walk out of here ready
to invest in your happiness portfolio
and be a happier person starting tonight.
Here's the good news: simple, available to
everybody,
and easy to understand. Here are the four:
faith,
family, community, and work.
Those are your big four. That's your
happiness portfolio.
Don't waste your time on other stuff.
Because if you do, you're going to be going in the wrong
direction. Family, I mean
I'm sorry, faith is pretty obvious. The
interior life, I'm not going to tell you which faith,
but thinking about the transcendental,
thinking about the things that are not
of this world, and
incorporating them into your life. Family,
having solid family relationships, these
are the things that can't and shouldn't
go away.
Community is a little bit more complicated,
the elements of community are
cultivating important friendships
and being charitable in your community
being a charitable person toward others.
That's what it means to have community
in your life. I'm not going to spend my time
0:12:43.389,0:12:45.070
on faith, family, and community.
I'm going to spend the rest of my time on work,
because that's the counter intuitive one.
Work is such a big deal, you watch "The
Office,"
you read Dilbert cartoons, right? Work is
just a drag, right?
At least for other people, you probably like your
job, but other people,
probably not so much. What percentage of
Americans like or love their jobs?
What percentage of Americans are
satisfied or very satisfied with their work?
Right, think about it, get a number in
your head, you're thinking twenty,
25 percent, eighty-nine percent.
Eighty-nine percent of americans are either
satisfied or very satisfied with their jobs.
What an incredible thing. No other
country comes even remotely close,
why? Why? Because of money?
No, that's not one of the big four, I
didn't say faith, family, community, work and money.
No, money's not on the list, and in
truth many economists, including me,
we've studied the effects of money on
happiness. Money
does bring happiness by relieving
pressure to people who are poor,
up to the level of the lower middle
class, then it flattens out a lot.
Brings a little bit but it takes a lot
of money at higher income levels to
bring any sort of satisfaction.
Right, so money is really not it, it's
something else. What
is it that brings so much happiness to
so many people from work?
Besides the guys who're bummed out at age
45.
So what is it? We've looked and we've looked
and we found it,
we found it. It's earned success.
It's the belief that you're creating value
with your life and value in the lives of
other people.
Earned success is truly the key to
happiness
through work. If you believe that you're
serving
others and you're creating value with
everything you do I don't care what you
do because
people who believe that they've earned
their success and are happy in their work
are the same whether they have a college
degree or a high school degree
or no high school degree, whether they
have above-average incomes
or below average incomes, whether they
classify themselves as lower-middle-class
or middle-class or upper middle-class it
doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter, it matters whether or
not they think they're creating value
with their lives that they are earning
their success.
If you take two people precisely the same the
data from the University of Chicago General
Social Survey
the best survey database that we have in
the United States today, two people who are
the same
age, sex, race, religion, same level of
education,
and they both say they've earned their
success, but one person earns eight times
as much money as the second,
they will be equally likely to say that
they are very happy about their lives.
What an incredible thing, money doesn't buy
happiness, earned success
is it, and that's what the guy
on the motorcycle has, that's what he
has.
He's earning his success, that's what we
want I want to be that guy,
why? I want to have life on my terms, I
want to build my life,
I want my life to be my enterprise.
That's the spirit of American
entrepreneurship that's the American dream.
Enterprise is not building a business,
enterprise is building your life.
And if you do it and you earn your success,
you pursue your happiness. That's the moral
covenant of our founders to us when they
talked about the fact that we're
endowed by our Creator with the unalienable
rights of life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness,
they might well have said
and earning our success. What an
incredible miracle.
It's not just happiness for you and me,
incidentally, happiness for everybody.
What's the difference between now and the
world I grew up in when I was a little kid?
When I was a little kid, 1970
what was poverty in the third world?
Poverty in the third world was
a picture in the National Geographic
with a kid with a distended belly
and flies on his face,
who is poor and was gonna die, and there
was nothing
I could do about it and there was nothing you
could do about it. That was poverty in
nineteen seventy,
comparing 1970 to today, the percentage of the
world's population
living on a dollar a day or less, that's
the standard measure of poverty among
development economists, the percentage of
the world's population
living on a dollar or day or less since 1970
has declined
by eighty percent, that's the world's
greatest
anti-poverty achievement ever. Is it
the fabulous success of the United Nations?
Is it,
it's not a laugh line my friends, is it
the International Monetary Fund or the
World Bank? Those might or might not be
effective organizations depending
on your point of view
but it's not those things, it's five things,
according to development economists it's
globalization, free trade,
property rights, rule of law, and
entrepreneurship.
Now you can give to charity all
day long
but you got to have a system that works
while you sleep. You got to have a system that
works
even when people are not trying to make
it work and that system exists, it's the
free enterprise system, what an incredible
miracle.
The earned success system that brings
you happiness is the system of free
enterprise
that lift people out of poverty, that lets
people live
around the world. This is the reason that the
free enterprise system
is not an economic alternative, as it's
often described,
the free enterprise system is a moral
imperative,
earned success needs the free enterprise
system,
poor people need the free enterprise
system. What is that system? It's a system
that matches our skills with our
passions, it's
a system that celebrates hard work and
merit and personal responsibility
and rewards opportunity, it's a system
where you can keep what you earn,
these are moral goals because they lift
people up,
not because they make people rich, forget
about making people rich. They let people
live their life as an enterprise,
that's what I accidentally found,
that's the guy on the motorcycle, that's
what people have a chance for the first
time in history,
to achieve in the third world, that's
what you can build
when you fight for the free enterprise
system. I want you to remember two things:
the pursuit of happiness sounds
complicated,
but it's really not. You have under your
control
the portfolio to give you the most happiness
possible.
Start paying attention more, more and
today,
to faith, family, community,
and work. Second, do you want the rest of
the country to be happier?
Do you want the rest of the world to have a
better shot at the happiness that
we feel is our moral right passed on by
our founders?
Then work for the system that makes it
possible, don't work for the socialism that
makes it harder,
don't work for the statism, the
collectivism that suppresses this,
work for the free enterprise that makes this
possible,
because if you do, if you do that,
then you're truly working for the common
good, and for that my last words to you,
are thank you.